So you the first half of season 7 was very
much about these characters, the audience
finding their way forward from incredible
trauma was really about all week is so
is broken have to morning and figure out how
we will let me put this to all of you as clearly
as I can.
I'm not in charge anymore the worst.
Rick just sent defeated it makes Rick believe
that the only way forward is compliance group
is to actually do this type of tyranny begins
with a man be going out of his way and risking
his life for knee can in order to preserve
life in Alexandria throughout the six sessions
moment changed his mind and makes him realize
that this is an untenable situation
by the end we see the all these characters
that have been different places I want to
sing.
The promise of the future.
Is that okay, they weren't ready to work in
a place to fight.
They are now there is this moment of optimism
one of the red red moments in this front-page
you know we are rebuilding together again,
or at least just the beginning of the resistance
that we just maybe my seven 15 people now
in a whole new place really strategize there
are some very practical obstacles
gained asking you to join us fighting, fighting
for freedom for all in the second half of
season seven is, and it is very different
can't be wine which is physical force won't
work building in seven Rick trying
to find someway breaking hey Youtubers, it's
Charlie walking dead is back in a couple weeks
let's break this down episode 9 is actually
going to air the weekend after the Super Bowl
the not going to try and beat the Super Bowl
usually The Walking Dead ratings actually
beat Sunday Night Football on a regular basis,
but in the United States is just the most
watch thing ever.
The night that it airs it's of like watching
the World Cup of soccer like everybody is
watching it tonight so it is foolish to try
and air some other big program against it.
So there will be a new walking dead giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video you can
kind see from the footage that this is all
march to war stuff.
Rick Grimes the survivors meeting with the
people at hilltop Jesus deciding to go meet
the kingdom and start to assemble their team
because everybody has something that the other
group needs need weapons.
That's where the kingdom comes in, but so
far as Ezekiel has had this policy where he
just try to appease the saviors, but now they're
trying to get him to step up.
They had that secret plan during the first
half of the season, to feed them the tainted
meat.
So they've already been trying to take down
the saviors.
At a very slow rate.
It's a bit of a long con because they haven't
really shown you the scope of the saviors
that sort of tease that idea like when was
shown is taking that woman to go kill Negan.
She points down the hill to all the people
that are assembled and says you might make
it past the couple of them, but there are
just so many their numbers are so great you
have zero chances.
So mission number one in the next couple of
episodes is assembling walking dead full Tron
so that Rick Grimes can take down Meagan,
but even beyond that we got a tease for these
garbage pail kids.
So like they say that there's going to be
more groups coming on we already know about
the really big ones, but there are even more
beyond that like that's how big the saviors
are they need is many as they can get even
the combined forces of the save zone hilltop
the kingdom Oceanside who also have a lot
of weapons, so the kingdom has armor, weapons,
sodas Oceanside two, so the really important
even all of them together won't be enough
to defeat needed in the saviors.
That's how big they are they have all the
satellite stations so that's where the secret
card comes in from the terrace episode that
everybody hated so much.
So there are important things that they bury
in the filler episodes and everybody complained
about that the like why we getting a Tara
episode but at least they snuck something
in that the pay off later there couple rumors
about Chandler Riggs status on the show because
he's going to schools all address that at
the end of this to.
So just to explain the key card theory the
best theory that I've seen so far is that
because the saviors use those satellite radio
stations to communicate.
That's where their real strength is as they
have like a couple people in satellite stations
all over the place so that they can marshal
their forces in an instant when they need
to, so in order to access this vast communication
network.
You need one of those key cards to get into
the buildings.
So that's probably what this is.
So when it seem like he's had bailed what
really probably happen is that he was taken
by the saviors that key card was left behind.
So that will be the key that they need to
start dismantling their communication network
and then they can start taking them off because
the group like Meagan you can't just take
them head-on they would totally lose got to
flank them take their advantages away and
that gets into their communication network.
See you guys can let me know how do you think
that they're going to start fighting the saviors
they got the tainted meat.
So far that the weapons from Oceanside and
now once they figure out what they have.
They can start taking them off one at a time
like the little pockets of the saviors before
they go full onto Meagan's home base.
So what about Chandler Riggs there's rumors
that what's can happen at the end of season
seven before season 8 is that they'll be a
time jump.
And it'll explain how Karl is getting so big
so fast.
So that doesn't mean that he's absolutely
done with the show that he will be on it a
little bit less.
This is what I'm expecting between classes
will come back on.
They can do flashbacks.
So that doesn't mean that they're going to
kill Karl off he still going to be walking
dead family will so come back on, but it won't
be as much is he's been on in the past, although
to be honest, there haven't been that many
Karl episodes to begin with.
So it's not like they're going to be changing
things a lot.
It just that you will notice him much less,
but it all depends on what he does with his
season 8 contract he just is.
Seven season contract was up.
So anything could change he could change his
mind and just film all of his stuff around
his school schedule, so he'll still be doing
walking dead stuff no matter what is just
a question of how much walking dead stuff
but what can happen this weekend because there's
not going to be an episode they will probably
drop some new footage so I'll do new video
in the next couple days later tonight I have
some new Marvel guardians of the galaxy, there's
new Star Wars episode 8 some new Game of thrones
I'll be posting so try to get that stuff out
as fast as possible while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for all my
walking dead season 7 videos and you can click
here to learn about the zombie flash on legends
of tomorrow.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see in the next video!